yo what's going on man it's Mr Fab the
mayor of the city man and we holding it
down with bootleg cab you already know
catch us on the podcast we got a couple
things to talk about you might want to
see
Blue Lake Cab podcast special guest in
here
Legend Mr Fab man welcome bro tell word
what's going down I'm good man it's
happy to be here man uh definitely
appreciate you reaching back out when we
reached out man a long time coming been
watching your grind man I love
everything that you're doing and how you
highlighting a lot of the artists man
it's beautiful thing to see you know
when our media begins to expand and
expound from people that are from the
culture man and I definitely have seen
you grinding for several years man and
I'm just happy to be here yes sir I'm
kind of uh frustrated because I can't
even buy your [__] online you don't have
a website no we keep it where you got to
come get it straight from us man that
creates our own ecosystem where can I
buy some some dope area oh I feel like
everything that's on the Internet is
fake it's not all the fake it's all
bootleg uh
the irony of that yeah but uh you have
to you have to go to Oakland yeah you
have to go to Oakland or tap into the
you know the intricacies of our
ecosystem man one of us me unk and uh
you got to get it from us directly I
think we did that intentionally though
right um I think a lot of
I've seen a lot of clothing companies
come and go just based off the fact of
they've been too accessible right and
then people bring the value of the brand
down by just frivolously wearing it and
not representing it as uh for the
culture like we represent a straight
straight strong harm strong arm on the
culture so you got to get it from us
it's kind of like we got to validate it
like let me see
you don't bear approve right yeah we got
you like yeah you either gotta go and
buy it or be tapped in be tapped in so
you know I'm gonna get you something I'm
gonna say I guess I'm not tapped in
you're most definitely tapped in man
definitely good packages and everything
man
um how's everything though I obviously
got the new album coming out this month
right every week bro we dropping you
know that's the thing with us right now
we're doing this line this year hashtag
PTA which is
the algorithms so we're dropping we're
dropping an album every other week every
other every two weeks there's an album
yeah so just dropping so for you
obviously you know we think of the Bay
Area I think it's like independent grind
I think of independent rappers with 20
30 albums you know for you what was the
uh thought process behind
you know trying to figure out how to
adjust that Bay Area Grime to the
algorithm to you know it's just PTA man
you know right now we're living in times
where you have hundreds and thousands of
artists that drop music
um consistently and it's so easy there's
no middleman now it's back in the day it
was hard to drop out right definitely
difficult to drop an album back then now
to take an advantage you have so many
different uh dsps and other other ways
to get your music to the masses right
our main thing is just
I'm one of those artists where I really
love music I really love being in the
studio creating working and that's a
daily thing for me even in the midst of
all the other businesses you can do it
for free I love it right so my main
thing is I still get high off creating
you know when I go in the studio I feel
like it's the my first day still right
and I go in there with something to
prove I go in there with something to
create I'm not one of those dudes that
go in the lab and just you know party
it's not my thing I'm like dude I'm in
here creating right I really like and
with my craft I love it like that so
saying all that to say you look in your
email you look at hundreds and you know
thousands of songs like no they're just
sitting
um why not put these out why not finish
them why not why just get them out yeah
you know get them out um and you never
know what can happen somebody can you
can wake up in the morning and your song
is going viral somebody has done a tick
tock to it right somebody wants to put
it in a movie you know and as we grow
and as we expand and expound the others
around us that have been in the creative
field they do as well so you have
directors that may be working on music
that may be working on movies like a lot
of things in Northern California right
now with you know the blind spotting
Ryan cougar is a childhood friend of
mine and these are people that reach out
like yo I need some music for this so
why not put it out man and you know like
I say hashtag PTA algorithms my biggest
advice to any artist out there there's
no perfect time to drop music so stop
waking yourself and stop thinking it
stop overthinking it you know um and
over uh analysts can cause paralysis
yeah and you'll be able and then you
stop and then you get tired of this [__]
that you know it's hot because you're
like man it's just old now get it out
then it don't come out and then get the
music out man get the music to the
people let the fans decide push the
music out and if it don't work drop some
more you're not being held or held
accountable to all man your last project
was trash we don't want to listen to
nothing else man just keep working man
you know keep grinding man that's you
know if you're an artist and this is
what you love to do do it I love it man
um for you you've obviously evolved into
such a leader of the bay like when I
think of the Bay Area I think of you I
think a 40 I think of a couple guys who
just kind of like
I feel like on all levels being an OG
um I always see you embracing the
younger generation I always see you kind
of evolving the hustle whether it's
doing content Now with uh we're doing uh
the store the clothing line
um still obviously keeping your finger
on the post of the music [__] for you
like what motivates you to
just keep the hustle strong man I feel
like you know it's it's in you it ain't
on you you know what I mean like I said
man I love it right you have to really
love what you do you know to continue to
do it especially when you're doing it
and it's not instant gratification it's
not instant right uh monetary you know
consumption and things like that we
really just do it man we love it you
know with me and Uncle uh which he's
here he's going to come on and and you
know and chill uh but embracing the
younger guys right showing the younger
guys look there's no age limit in it
it's no there's no expiration date and
creativity
you know what I'm saying that's real and
and remain creative continue to keep
doing I tell people Quincy Jones helped
create Thriller at 50 years old
that's why I just think yeah I'm saying
that's that's one of his biggest
contributions to music and one of the
biggest songs in music
you think about the uh the Asian dude
who just won the best actor last night
he was like he was the little kid that
died on Indiana Jones I've seen that
yeah they hugged and reenacted kind of
like that same thing which is kind of
crazy yeah but that that's like that's
what it is like you know you look at
icons and legends like Nas winning his
first Grammy a couple years ago yeah
after all of the things that he's done
after after Illmatic and it was written
like yeah like we we look at these
things and we say look at what our icons
have been doing I I come under as you
alluded uh the e40s and you know the two
the two shorts Mac Dre's nicotineas and
then several of the the icons that have
done uh they have pioneered what it is
to be an independent artist right so
just following that blueprint and then
uh inoculating the things that I'm doing
to show some of the younger guys look it
don't have to just stop with music we
have I have a clothing store I have a
nightclub I have a museum I have uh nail
shops I didn't know you had a museum
yeah the dope area experience so oh wow
um it's it's it's just a a canvas that
we're gonna um allocate to other schools
and everything we're opening up our
school and this summer The Dope Air
Academy which is just a a it's like a
course for to teach entrepreneurialism
and other things to help these people
these young kids jump the curve to be
able to say dude we got to start our
kids early right we got to start our
kids in a position to say dude let's get
you in the game early one thing with us
in the culture that we come from
sometimes
our parents have taught us like you're
too young for that instead of
this is how you do it right right don't
touch that you're too young to that nah
we have to change that narrative and
break that monotony of not teaching and
not educating so I'm very you know I'm
huge on that so that's what all it is
with me man in a nutshell is just keep
leading that keep going and embrace the
Next Generation don't hog space so long
right and embrace Nick there's room for
everybody yeah come on man yeah for sure
for you uh I feel like San Francisco and
the bay and Oakland were
probably as heavily impacted by the
pandemic as like a lot of cities because
you know with extreme wealth comes with
extreme poverty
um
when I go to the banks I I try to make
it out there probably like four or five
times a year
for Empire [__] and um it feels like
like at least in the city it feels like
a lot of energy has kind of gotten
pulled out of it now every time I go
everyone's like it's Oakland is where
you want to be Oakland's where you know
the nightlife is still thriving and you
know for you being somebody from Oakland
and just kind of assessing like the
state of the bay as a city as a as a
metropolitan area rather
um how do you feel like you feel like
it's bouncing back at all
or because because I you know I was at
um trying to go to a [__] Walgreens
in San Francisco and that [__] was just
not open because of the the you know
everyone was stealing [__] out of there
it's tough man yeah um
and before we address the secondary we
must address the primary you know we're
in uh the economical deficit is
definitely has infected and impacted
right um and most of the times when this
happens uh you hear the wealthy complain
about the loss of their wages and riches
and things of their businesses that are
slowing down but the flip side to that
is what about those that don't have
those businesses to be affected right so
if poverty imagine how they're affected
so if poverty if the wealthy are being
affected imagine how impactful and
affected people who are living in
poverty but poverty and so what that
does is that induces all of the other
things crime goes up
you know the violence uh and the
impoverished mindset right so in that
mindstate you look at a lot of the
people that are involved that are trying
to rise above their areas that they're
coming from it's it's it becomes crucial
man it becomes uh
it's a sad state right you know it's a
sad state where I can't come visit you
at your store because I'm worried about
if my windows are going to get broken
into right I can't come uh patronize
your nightclub because I don't know if
I'm going to get robbed going leaving my
club you know I'm saying leaving the
club so that's the the climbing and the
sending it uh the sentiments that we
that we deal with and we have to factor
into these equations but you can't blame
them for doing what they're doing out of
an active survival yeah I mean that's
and that's that's the other the other
side of the coin like the law of I think
it's you could steal under a thousand
dollars like if you have no money
and you're starving
and you could go
get your food and get your whatever you
need and nothing gonna happen to you I
mean you're gonna do it or not you know
what I mean you're gonna we we have to
stop being so judgmental and judging
right or wrong in situations that's
eat or starve yeah it's like context to
every situation like you know what I'm
saying and and there's people who are
going to take advantage of that who
might not be starving yeah most
definitely most definitely you know um
it's hard to not be empathetic but then
it's also understanding that you know I
don't I don't want to be
naive to the situations that's going on
so
yeah like I say you know I there is is
what it is man and you just you just
hope you know keep your fingers crossed
and hope that you and your family are
protected man and that people find their
way
um and then as someone like myself as an
influencer continue to keep leading by
example to show people how to create
your own Wills right and you know and
creating creating those Wills you can uh
quench The Thirst of many in your
village I saw was it your daughter whose
car got bit her uh her mother okay yes I
saw like what you posted was it her
schoolwork that got her schoolwork yeah
and you were like hey I get it as part
of the game I get it but can I get my
daughter's backpack back get it like
like people
people love the game
until the rules
hit them and now they want to change the
rules right bro we in it we know what we
signed up for we know where we live in
we know you know you can't change the
law of the Jungle right right right
right you know what I mean and we
understand that and no one is is immune
to being affected by you're not above it
like you're you're not above now I don't
care what you're doing if you if you in
this you know what it is it's just like
if you're in the game and you signed up
for something you got to come even when
it ain't in your favor so as I say you
know my my uh my public service
announcement you know to the bippers out
there like hey man hey if you guys you
guys hit this car yeah I didn't know if
you got the bag man ain't nothing in
there but some homework I need it yeah
that's it and so
um it has worked before
um it didn't work that time right it has
worked before
um
the relationship you know some of the
guys you know these young guys
um they're the they're the mass
Crusaders so sometimes you may know him
and don't even know that you know him
and that's true and they'll follow you
like oh man my bad I didn't know and you
know come drop it off but uh man my
daughter is such a warrior man she was
able to steal Ace all of her finals and
everything
um Straight A's to wait till it was like
her homework her notes it was her notes
oh her notes and it was a week before
finals you know yeah and uh she's she's
uh she's a champ for sure she's such a
champ man and she's like she's she is so
devoted to school man um and getting
into uh she wants to go
um
to you know like an MIT or things like
that so she's she's super dedicated
still aced her finals Straight A's man
and I'm proud of her which uh Golden
State Warrior at any time you answered
you think you can get to answer the
phone
it's difficult
um
like if real close someone if someone
said I have a million dollars you have
to get a warrior to answer the phone
Who you calling
clay clay uh
uh I mean that's a good warrior to to
you know to you know those are my
brothers like yeah I mean like you would
have to give me a time frame like all
right give me a window yeah like give me
a window of time like you know what I'm
saying but pretty much
Gary's gonna answer anytime who's now
back on the team you know so so Gary
Gary's going to answer any time will you
chat with his with his dad yes of course
of course yeah
um GPS from Oakland for sure
um that's where we get all that [__]
talking me and step me and Steph are
like super close like me and Steph have
a
super close relationship man but you
know this is we have to be mindful of
who Steph Curry is
so yeah I'm saying stuff like I'm not
just gonna call you yeah so it's like
I'm not just oh yeah that's a that's a
tough thing like to be like oh yes
Steph's gonna answer that you know I
would be lying right uh but will he text
back and will he call of course so it
just has to be a time window though man
but I I pretty have a a great
relationship with all of the fellas man
you know um you know Dre's little bro
and we just continue to keep building
man you know I love those guys
um for you
is it frustrating as a Warriors fan to
see they're like the number one
bandwagon team now in the last like
decade no and I'm like nobody was ruined
for the [__] Warriors when it was
Monta Ellis right and David Lee and then
before that it was like Steven Jackson
you know even when it was like Run DMC
right nobody was was there but now it's
like they're like you know the the IT
team did do you get frustrated to see
like bandwagon Warrior fans not at all
that's what winning does
um you know you you want to be able to
say man let's continue to expand the
bandwagon man let's keep going that that
lets us know that we're winning
um you have Yankee fans that probably
can't tell you one person on the team
they just love the pitch right Cowboys
fans you got Cowboys fans you know all
of these franchise man you know the like
the Patriots of course the Lakers fans
I've seen so many Bay Area people that I
know that were Lakers yeah most
definitely was Lakers now they're
Warrior fans a lot of them
convenient you're full of [__] well bro
I grew up my my dad
Magic Johnson I had a Magic Johnson
Jersey at four I'm like come on man cut
it out but uh you know it is what it is
like we you that's what comes with
winning man um I definitely salute the
fans that have were there during the
tough times and you know
um that's what I'm happy about I'm just
happy to see some of those people still
going strong yeah for sure shout out to
what was his name bertrands what was the
guy's name the big German [__] Center
the white boy
Beatrice yeah whatever he was Lithuania
he died he had to die so uh jokic could
exist yeah
people forget that he was an All-Star
right but he's just like he wasn't an
All-Star but he was good but he let the
league and uh in field goal percentage
he was good yeah yeah he's pretty good
man pretty good dude he's like Slovakian
Lithuanian something like that he was
pretty good and his wow his girl oh my
God we gotta say we could find a picture
of her man his girl was so fun oh my God
so yeah I remember those days yo if
someone comes to the Bay they're
visiting
what's the advice so they don't get
bipped are we like you land you get your
rental car you got all your luggage
let's say I'm hungry I'm gonna eat am I
taking all the luggage out of the car
putting it in a restaurant with me most
definitely okay
when you pull up roll your windows down
roll all the windows down you know most
people pull up and be like roll the
windows up we getting out no when you
pull up roll the windows down
I don't care what the weather is but
roll the windows down okay and take
everything out of your car
don't risk it the great advice is go to
the room first or go to your Airbnb put
your stuff up don't leave
don't leave us a Safeway bag in the
backs don't leave nothing
a [__] charger nothing because what
happens is they identify the cars and
they're like oh that's a rental they
know so they know it's a rental like
it's a science to it right so it's a
rental like oh he got a brand new
Chrysler 300. oh we got him we got a
rental and then people be thinking
this is the biggest reason why most
people get bipped those hazards
those hazards let a person know that you
coming right back to the car so
it's evident that you've left something
in the car since you're coming right
back that fast
that's a red that's a hey something's in
here that's a green light yeah we yeah
because it happens so like you could go
you could go to that door to the front
door right here
the bit pulls up so fast
by the time you get back here you like
oh so hey yeah man roll your windows
down you come to the Bay Area roll your
windows down you're not safe don't think
just because you're going into Starbucks
and anything like that you are not safe
roll the windows down you will be highly
disappointed just allow them to open the
door and go through it man and there's
nothing that there's no chain of command
so you can't call the big homie you
can't call the rapper to be like man can
you get my stuff bro that's gone it's
probably some 14 year old 15 year old
who don't even know who your big homie
is he don't know nuts no protocols no
chain of command it's none of that this
is get it how you live they eat you feel
me they out are the Kia boys eating out
there right now because in La there's
just a lot of little kids stealing kids
with USBS right now man it's all kind of
stuff you got the Scat Cat boys the
Hellcat because you know they got the
whole you know the bay is a little bit
more technical technologically uh
technologically advanced it's Silicon
Valley it's some silicon game going on
there's some pull up to your car with
the iPad reprogramming Hellcat we'll
we'll get the key on God wait so what do
they do man you got the reprogrammer so
you got to when you get in the car you
got to reprogram it putting it under the
thing reprogram the key
Pope started up it's serious that's
amazing it's a whole different level of
uh similar thievery going on out there
someone will disable your key on God and
bring a new key and just reprogram it
that's impressive the youngsters is man
they Advance that's why I'm I'll be
telling us like dude y'all taking all
this time for Crime imagine if you did
something positive with it like imagine
if you created the anti-program where
now you can deactivate somebody that's
trying to program like you can win be
smart use your talents for a great like
you're out here reprogramming vehicles
in a very hot in a highly stressful
situation with a very small amount of
time you can work on something different
but you're under a lot of stress you
could be diffusing bombs for the FBI
come on man you got talent kid yeah a 14
year old 15 year old Kitty like
um then the way he explained it to you
is so funny uh all you gotta do bro take
the iPad put it under the thing when you
get the key boom it's gonna pop up the
app is gonna show up so then you
reprogram it right then you got about 90
seconds once you get it you click it
boom then you you get up out of there
and then you're gonna take it to the
Mexicans the Mexicans gonna give you
three four thousand for him bro just
chop it down crazy bro that's amazing
y'all I got too much time when you say
I'm on my brand that's all I be looking
for bruh I'm either gonna bip or give me
a Hellcat brand I know I could go give
me a quick three four thousand dollars
real fast bro say bro y'all it's crazy
bro stay away from the hellcats for real
hellcats and scats you will get
reprogrammed man
we could get you too grab your Lambo
that's not safe bro let me see this key
oh yeah I can reprogram this one I could
reprogram this right you got to be cool
leaving your key in the car huh
that [__] is crazy I think back one of
the um viral moments when in the blog
area that you had was when you know in
my opinion one of the greatest rappers
of all time fell death to your sword on
stage and I'm talking about Royce the
five nine love rush you guys had a
battle and
I think Royce is one of the greatest of
all time
you bodied him it was rough no it was
because I feel like you caught him off
guard there was a lot more factors into
what happened right right it wasn't like
Royce got killed but like the
circumstances did not line up favor
before Royce he was caught off guard a
little bit I also don't think Royce came
there like
I mean you could kind of give me a
little background what happened that
night because it's on YouTube right and
not a lot of people can say
I shot the Fate on stage with Royce to
rapping and I got him right
um I caught him off guard that night I
don't think that he knew
um
competitively what we were supposed to
do that night okay
um I think one thing that was told to me
was we're gonna have a freestyle battle
with this person this person this person
and everybody's going to be there
um one guy didn't show up
um I think something happened to
something something did happen to Joe
Budden's brother that night so Joe was
supposed to be there right and and this
is why I tell people all the time here's
uh here's a good hairline a headline for
us
that night created slaughterhouse
um
because Joe Button was supposed to
perform that night unfortunately
something had happened to his brother
which prevented him from coming which
left me and Royce to battle and duel so
when we got up there to battle I don't
think that he understood that it was
like that kind of battle like it's more
like everybody just look just get a
versa
so I caught him off guard
um
me being the young you know
super guy just
excited you know for one him being one
of my favorite rappers he's a goat to
being like yo I get a chance to spar
with
with Royce tonight yeah I'm bringing the
best shot I'm going I'm swinging so you
know what I'm saying so
um we did that so then that led to Joe
and Royce having words
I forgot they had the little beef yeah
this is before slaughterhouse right so
that night created slaughterhouse yeah
because off of their beef is how they
kind of yeah cool so then it was like
Joe was like
you Royce y'all whack you know Joe Joe
gets in his bag and he was like whatever
like you're not even in my own lane and
then Joe and Royce
I mean uh Joe and Royce and then me and
Royce and they were like
we did what we did
and then they were they went and then
they
you know that was uh that began into it
kicked off that whole wave of events for
real so it conflated they came together
they got Joel and and uh and crooked and
creative people who was on that first
song Nino bless was on a song with them
and he was like there there was a song
called slaughterhouse and I think it was
five of them but they didn't end up
including Nino blessed so j-o crook yeah
and Joe and then they created you know
arguably one of the dopest groups you
know especially first album was amazing
for sure man to be able to watch all of
those dudes just trade bars this is
super dope man it was funny because
my dude came to me one day he was like
cuz
man you helped spark that bro they could
at least put you on a song or something
bro I say man that's crazy I say man
they in a different League man you know
we we the underground we like the dude
that beat Tyson in prison and nobody
knows his name we just heard the rumors
of Tyson lost a fight in jail what is
interesting too because I do feel like
uh for whatever reason is still
happening but in terms of like
the Bay Area if you go to the Bay it is
very much like its own
like you're like in your own country
kind of for sure pop it's like an island
like you go to the club you're gonna
hear [__] you're gonna hear songs from
people who aren't from the bay that you
won't hear anywhere else like you'll
hear some baby boy the prince or
something like for sure you'll just hear
[__] that like only worked there the way
we live still gets play and the best
that's what I mean like like that way
that record I think one of the young
guys just redid that beat or something
or he's planning to redo that beat that
record is still big and people like
never even heard that record it's so
crazy because like it is indeed
its own Island and I think that there's
like gifts and curses with that while
also being like one of the most
influential places in hip-hop
there's so many things you can trace
back to the Bay Area right
um why do you think
you know 20 years later now you you have
a lot of context to your career and and
and just you know observing the music
industry that the base still somehow
doesn't get the flowers or respect you
think it deserves because I think it
deserves a lot more love and respect you
know in terms of of the landscape of
hip-hop you look at Independent Artists
that have dealt with
mainstream artists that have been backed
by Powerhouse machines and
you can't
there's no equivalence to an independent
artist pushing out his own product
versus a label that's pushing millions
and correct and you know I'm saying
hundreds of thousand dollars behind a
single correct for someone who's pushing
a couple pennies towards a project you
know um and and that's at the end of the
day that's what it is like the
difference is as Independent Artists
we've created an infrastructure that has
solely been based off a friend a fan
artist type relationship
um we look at what La Russell is doing
right now killing it and that's all just
fan base that's all it's building a
community this whole community and this
ecosystem is that's what
um to marginalize the Bay Area in a
nutshell that's what it is it's just
artists that have succeeded in respected
markets with the art with with the fans
and the group of people that support
them and they just focus on them like
you may take the hottest artists in the
country
um
and put him against somebody in the bay
that that may be thriving there
demographically and they do a show
they're going to be people that are
going to be going to that to that base
to that artist from the Bay's record or
if they put them on the same show that
artist's gonna be like damn why y'all
let me open like someone just brought
Dilo out like a few months ago and it
was crazy it was that YG was it white I
feel like it was like somebody else YG
Kalani it was maybe it was Kaylani
kelani did Kaylani yeah yeah yeah okay
Lonnie brought him out
um about three months ago yeah I think
that's what I was yeah I remember seeing
that I'm like this is an r b show I mean
obviously she's from the bay you know so
a little little but but I was just like
that's so tight she brought him out and
then YG brought him out about a month
ago same energy
um D-Lo has hit the ground running he
just you know came home from prison and
just been hitting the ground running and
like I told him
he's so influential he doesn't even know
right he was a kid when that record was
probably 16 years old 17 years old and
all of these years later that record is
still
the number one records in the in the
party starting record sure and so now
this is about him getting out and
expanding and continuing to keep moving
forward but um you see that uh time's
over in the bay there's so many
different artists that are doing there's
a young artist named Cato who has a
record called go off that went viral on
Tick Tock and you don't see people
working records anymore and like I was
telling him though put some y'all never
even worked that record right I'm like
call this person some energy behind it
yeah put some energy behind it like if
you really put some energy behind this
record say I didn't watch y'all below 20
30 000 and on the weekend in the club or
something go put that behind somebody
call you know this guy and say man can
you work this record help me get this
record yeah I see like the stuntman kid
has been working his record for two
years two years now two years and
Thunderman his energy alone he's just a
good person great kid he's got his he's
got an amazing line of organic juices
that taste amazing he's just a great kid
great his energy for sure like his
energy is just he's just a great kid man
so it's hard to not like him like we
were in I was uh he records at at my
home studio
um like where I do all my work at
um Studio X and he he came in the other
day
and he was like Uncle man what did it
take to get you on the song I'm like
what
I'm like load up what you want me to get
on
has happened I got this one but then I
might have liked it this one but this
one sound cool too
I just did three verses for him real
quick yeah well then pick what you like
just take whatever one he was like but
that's you know that's the type of
organic energy that we own man right
there man and and that camaraderie can
continue to help bridge what has ever
been separated in there you got a lot of
guys that are that are working extremely
hard from all cities up in the Bay San
Francisco is really thriving Oakland EPA
Berkeley Richmond and most definitely
Vallejo and Sacramento which a lot of
people won't consider the bay Stockton
and Sacramento right Stockton's on fire
Stockton's crazy like the whole Stockton
movement is on fire like yeah and
unfortunately that you know I know they
lost the slow B guy but rest in peace to
slowly and Stockton is but all the ebk
all those guys though I mean those guys
are crazy and then we just seen Haiti
baby get signed with CTE which easy so
you know yeah I always like though there
it is it is funny because you'll you'll
hear like you'll talk like you'll talk
to certain people for and they're from
like Sacramento
and or or Stockton and then you'll ask
them if they don't think that you know
better like where are you from from the
bay I'm
from Sac I said right but now Sac has
created
its own representation sure now they
just like it's just like that noise
in Sacramento now they're claiming
they're actually sure for sure so you
know what I'm saying you know you
contribute uh the mazis and the CMLS you
know and and all of the DB body bags and
all of these other artists that have
done tremendous work to grab them their
identity in the continuance of the
sibo's and the x-rays the root dogs and
brother Lynch's and these guys that have
that have done it for years marvelous
one of the first female rappers to be on
the scene got about sibo yeah come on
like you like sibo is a a Pioneer man
sure independent Pioneer independent
like this is there would be no sack
music scene without
sibo and you know in Black Market you
know when I was a little dude when I was
a little kid I bought a season of the
sickness for Brother Lynch brother Lynch
well I didn't buy it my best friend had
the CD and I was probably like seven
eight and I believe that he was eating
I love Brother Lynch man brother Lynch
and so when I was a little kid I
remember like listening to his [__] and
my mom heard it and lost her [__]
mind like what the hell is this listen
do you want to win some money gotta stop
the interview but listen there's so many
opportunities to gamble to bet on your
favorite sports to make Sports more
interesting NFL season is over but it's
all good because the opportunities to
win are just getting started yeah look
there's so many things you can do we're
talking about NCAA NBA NHL UFC boxing
there's Blackjack tournaments so much
money to get in on and check this out
y'all if you sign up right now using the
promo code bootleg do it right now you
can get a welcome bonus up to a thousand
dollars plus you're gonna get a free 150
000 March Madness bracket contest entry
that's
mybookie.ag use the promo code bootleg
right now get a bonus up to a thousand
dollars you're gonna put in 200 bucks
they could give you 200 you put a
thousand they'll give you another
thousand right look right now go to
mybookie.ag sign up use that promo code
March Madness is upon us so much great
Sports just NBA season playoffs are on
the way man you could like literally put
together some crazy props like uh I
don't know over under on a player that
you like scoring you could do a future
on the MVP do you think jokic is going
to win it you think Joel embiid is going
to win it Whatever It Is get in on the
action right now mybookie.ag with that
promo code bootleg when you sign up get
that free deposit bonus all right bet
anything anytime anywhere with my bookie
also shout out to our family at hardean
Harding Las Vegas Yes you see him
I was just there in Vegas yesterday this
is the best place I've ever been to in
terms of dispensaries I've been to
probably hundreds of these things and
the experience at hardean is like
nowhere else
the customer service the selection of
Premium cannabis the experience as a
customer that you get when you walk into
the building in Las Vegas is a bar none
the best it's just the best man they are
the best we got so much going on this
weekend they're sponsoring the Rolling
Stone party on Friday Super Bowl weekend
fabulous Thursday offset Friday Meek
Saturday it's a lot going on with hard
Dean you got to follow him at hardean
underscore Las Vegas right now shoot him
a follow on Instagram while you're at it
go to their website hardinglasvegas.com
so much fly gear so much fly weed what
are we talking about baby shout out to
hard Dean man that's the family man go
if you're in Vegas pull up on them man
Jardine Las Vegas she because he had a
record you better pray wouldn't you put
that knot up in that [__] hole [__] it
back slow rock it back and forth wait
for the nut and let my trigger go boom
[__] guts all over the room and the
whole song is about eating like servings
maybe nuts and baby guts yeah he's
serving his own children baby Parts
Lynch was crazy like let's
unfortunately Lurch actually did it
remember yeah I didn't know that large
wigged out on some PCP and actually ate
someone
that he was hanging out with Brother
Lynch yeah that was a whole crew like
they they was they crew like well yeah
he actually he was inspired by hip-hop
so well but not sad I didn't know that
yeah he's actually in jail for that
right now [__] well that's x-rayed it's
out driving straight is out strange
um I feel like strangers might have
tried anything for trying to sign you
with a Tech N9ne Travis we spoke I did a
they push a hard line super hard I mean
they're strict it's like it's kind of
like it's kind of like a boot camp it's
a boot camp for boot camp for sure like
you go on tour and get fined and [__] me
and Tech are like this like that's
that's my brother man and take a show me
so much love and game I remember my
first time going to Kansas City doing
the show shortly after uh Max Ray was
assassinated
um
Tech came to the show and was like I'm
not letting nothing happen
it was there security guards I'm talking
about from me entering
Kansas City to me leaving he was with me
right and I was just like
how did you get my number like this is
like like he just called me like what's
up it's Tech Nine I'm like Tech what's
up where you at
right man you got candy tonight right
I'm pulling up
and he just stayed with me it's like
nothing's going to happen to you for
people who don't know Mac Dre was
murdered in Kansas City man and and um
Tech
uh
and Joe and like the whole Squad Travis
made sure that he was cool man and like
man like yeah but the Strange Music like
bro
they so militant like
when Ted goes on tour Tech does like 98
days 98 dates in like 100 in 100 days
right it's kind of wild it's no rooms
you're showering at and he's expecting a
baby right now I don't know how that's
gonna happen like bro you sure in that
truck stops for sure you got to get up
at six in the morning you got to deal
with those those strange music fans who
are special kind of fan
to all the all the ingredient the
sign-ins and all that's done so you
might have performed at nine o'clock
you're not leaving that City till two
o'clock right
you got to be at the next city at a
certain time you got a shower I said I
went out I say
to bougie for this that's so funny I
don't know I don't want to be this type
of successful this is a different level
listen says I love my freedom brother I
want to shower in a nice place I am the
room type I am the the I got to go go to
the hotel I got to catch an airplane man
I can't do it like I'm I don't know say
it wasn't meant for me to get to get on
that way sometimes you got to realize
man you got to really applaud those
people that put in that extra effort and
Tech N9 is the reason why he is and the
reason why they're successful as they
are because the behind the scenes work
that they put in oh my God the average
artist wouldn't last that's a real rap
boot camp like that's like Dude you
coming to here it's there you got to be
ready for sure so I love them and I
salute them like for what they do man
them dudes are definitely deserving of
everything that they get
um I think some people
who aren't from the bay might not
understand the gravity of Mac Dre right
I think that for a lot of people
Mac Dre wasn't a thing until he passed
and that's how they found out about him
now obviously in in the bay he's a lot
different but I had heard prior to him
passing he was more embraced by like the
like more nerdy like like Berkeley like
rap hippie [__] like explain to me kind
of the dynamic of Mac Dre like and his
kind of career and how things change in
in the way he was perceived after he
passed even even from like somebody like
yourself I think even the misconception
of Berkeley like we we people graph
Berkeley from Telegraph street and they
think that that's just Berkeley like
Berkeley is Hood like you know what I'm
saying you got the South Berkeley's the
waterfronts like so
all Berkeley not just what you see on
Telegraph street like Everson Berkeley
is like a it's a real spot like it's a
hood spot so
um his fans though to you know support
what you were saying he had a fan base
um before he before he got out of jail
like people forget the California living
people forget they're too hard for the
radio on his first run right where he
sold you know hundreds of thousands of
Records
um and is it safe to say that was before
the Fizz face for sure way before that
then you know he went to the federal
penitentiary
um for trumped up charges and he refused
to uh tell on his friends he did about
five and a half years and he came out
and his philosophy was man I'm just
gonna have fun right I'm gonna just kick
it make some party music and chill and
Miami
created you know the term this and it
was just about just having fun like
doing the hippie like creating the the
modern day hip-hop hippie right and uh
a lot of people don't understand
he went I won't say under the wing but
let's say side by side with Andre
Nickatina and nicotine was like it was
another Legend who doesn't super icon
who you won't get an interview out of
you want anything
um but still does like random shows yeah
he'll do he when he wants to yeah you'll
be like 100 nicotine is performing here
like he's doing this he's doing this
thing now with the symphony where
they're doing he's like the San
Francisco Symphony is doing his music
and like Nikki's I think gazi was
telling me about that I love Nikki like
like Nikki is the dude where he's a he's
a guru man he'll he talked to you in
Parables and it's just like you sit up
and he'd be like
see all that [__] just missed me being a
kid from Phoenix like the Mac Dre Andre
Nickatina I was listening to E40 in a
major way I was listening to all the two
short [__] so they were underground like
hieroglyphics but like and and like uh
Celly Cell [__] like that but that like
underbelly dog was like Dre Dog is you
know that's nicotine that's like the
under undercut so Dre and Dre and Dre
hooked up so nicotina and and
and uh Mac Dre hooked up
and Dre was like I'm gonna introduce you
to these other fans
to these fans that's supportive to these
fans that's going no matter what you do
right and we went out on tour and it was
a nicotina tour
and me I was like I thought
Mac Dre was bigger than Nikki right
until I went to the Seattles and the
olympias and the Salems and the the
bellinghams and I was like oh it's
different he's bringing them out yeah
like Nikki huge so I got a chance to go
on a Canadian tour with nicotina and I
was just I was blown away because I'm
like we're going in the cities you can't
I can't even pronounce the city and I'm
just like the lines wrapped around the
corner and like nicotine is just like
wow so that's the fan base they had they
had like you know big shout outs to
Santa Rosa Sebastian pool Petaluma Ukiah
humbled all of these small cities that
people bypass the normal mainstream
hip-hop they go right by those these
cities but these guys made a career off
showing love to those fans right and um
until this day those fans are very still
supportive man and and that's the bay
area's chitlin circuit where they go
because yeah that's real it's like you
get kind of that whole you could go to
Boise
from from Seattle to San Diego and then
we jump over because of course we go to
Arizona we go Boise and from that area
that whole little that chitlin circuit a
Bay Area an artist
can make a living
and now two and a good one and now La
artist it's the same time most
definitely most definitely because the
sound is similar yeah because the LA
[__] like I've noticed like guys like
you know I'm always trying to talk to
some of my friends and be like hey you
know like how do we get past get you
past Arizona or get you past Albuquerque
right you know what I mean right because
that's really the key a kid named Kaylin
for real for real did a good job because
he just moved to Atlanta for like a year
he went crazy when he came to the Bay
yeah so like but he went to the South
and tried to break there first and it
kind of worked in his favor because you
know now he can go to Atlanta and do a
show but I do think that chitlin circuit
is a real thing yeah you have you have
to tap into the chilling circuit because
something that people lack nowadays that
they allow social media to confuse them
into thinking just because you have
followers that you have fans true and
that's a difference fans break bread
they'll buy the shirt followers like
nosy neighbors right your followers are
the people that just want to look and
they peek through the window for sure
but the difference between followers and
fans are those fans are going to say
dude I'm going I want I want that
picture I want to be I want that
autograph memorable here's a tattoo by
the way Hey listen right you know I need
that you know and then that fan is
they're going to subscribe to your tribe
and that's how you become successful
that's how somebody passed the
Mississippi may not have never heard of
Mr Fab or
Pastor Rockies may not have never heard
of Mr fab right but you come to our area
and you're like wow you you have all of
these entities and you have this
influence and you you ride around town
and Lamborghinis and Maseratis you do
all of these things you know all of the
things that they're in all by right but
it's because we wouldn't be anything
without the fans and so our chitlin
circuit is uh it's it's very impactful
and thriving especially if you go out
and you involve yourself and dedicate
with him
so why do you think uh and I might be
wrong but was Mac Dre more embraced by
the inner city after he passed or was
his influence recognized more once he
passed away in terms of just kind of
like the hyphy movement and like what
kind of came after his death because I
feel like after Mac Dre passed away is
really when
the haifi movement took on a whole new
level and I can you know obviously you
can give a lot of credit to a lot of
people but I think might get a report
card is kind of what brought the hyphy
move into the world
um but like why do you think that his he
wasn't maybe necessarily appreciated as
much as he is now
um
I I
never I've never been the guy I'm not
like I've never been a Big Mac Dre fan
so like I try to understand that because
I go to the Bay I'm like God damn it
this [__] I went and bought a
Mac Dre soda in Vallejo you know what
I'm saying it's
A hip-hop fan who's never heard
A J dilla beat who would argue that J
Dill is one of the best producers ever
I just had this kid cash kid from
Detroit who's from Detroit and I said
have you ever heard of Jay Dillon and he
was like oh what's that I was like so
like it's just it's just like
what comes with
the post
it's people just automatically begin to
give you
a certain amount of Praise or they
continue just because they feel and
that's unfortunate because I think we
just saw it with Nipsey most definitely
like the world stopped when Nipsey died
and it was like where were these people
at when nips was alive for sure like you
know now give it credit that there were
a lot of people that loved Nick for sure
but was it like that right right right
you know what I'm saying was it was it
like that it's almost like he had to to
be fully appreciated for everything he
was doing it's like they're there seldom
do you see artists get a chance to
receive that love while they are alive
right
um I think Mac Dre was able to receive
that and
the world that he was in right he was
able to feel that
um he dropped the DVD called Trill TV
and and this is just being and
transparency people in Oakland was just
like okay that's Vallejo That's The Romp
that's that's them that's they doing
their thing they wasn't really super
crazy Mac Dre fans Not the majority of
course you have fans that were already
previous fans uh you know in the
formation of what we talked about right
uh
but when Trill TV came out and people
was like
bro this is how you living right like
Trill TV showed him an effect where he
had G-Wagon he had the Platinum chain he
had to grill he was like it he became a
superstar right
and for a long time the Bay Area hadn't
saw that they hadn't saw somebody in the
benzes and and the things that he had
the chains and the watch and they was
like oh this
Cuddy this [__] Saucy he like I want to
be him like I'm saying now people want
to they they started
aspiring to be like him the lifestyle so
that gave him a level of star power that
you know it it was it was an avalanche
and
on his incline unfortunately what took
place took place so he was he was Rising
back up on the end and so that momentum
still pushed forward after he passed and
people were just like bro y'all yeah
y'all seen that but y'all didn't get a
chance to see it so it became folklore
it was like folklore it was it was Urban
folklore it was like y'all didn't get a
chance to see it yep we was there like
we saw ma like people tell you their
stories of his star power you know I'm
saying it's like you know Jesus people's
got to talking about we don't know if
those stories was true it's like man for
real he touched the [__] man and he
cured leprosy man yeah well he took the
bread and cut the fish up and fed
everybody was like you know the folklore
begins to expand and so that's what it
was with Dre but if you asked me was he
able to feel or smell those Roses I do
believe that he was because he was able
to see his impact and how impactful that
it was becoming in his Resurgence and
unfortunately it was cut short
um
40 and Warner did a hell of a job with
packaging up
the hyphy movement and selling it right
shout out to Little John too most
definitely that was all the you know
Warner Little John tvt 40 they did a
great movement in pushing it forward and
a lot of people capitalized off of it
um from you know monetary perspective
right but I feel like the whole
package of seeing it all if they would
have got a chance to see it all it it
would have been amazing like if you
would have got a chance to see Too Short
40 Mac Dre key right you know and then
the younger Federation the team Fabs and
the church talks and all the other guys
that played a significant role in
keeping that snowball going into an
avalanche I think he would have got a
chance to see uh it being broader and
being more spoke about rather than just
the folklore of what it was and what it
could have been do you feel like
um for you being do you feel like right
now like everything's in good hands in
in the bay in terms of just the up and
coming generation because I think a guy
like Simba who's kind of a young OG he's
kind of like a you know he's been around
right uh the Russell I think is changing
a lot of the way Independent Artists all
over the world are thinking about their
business model and what it means to be
an artist like how do you feel about the
new generation I love those guys I love
Simba I love Russell I actually just did
um Fab week which is my annual birthday
party weeks and I brought drink Champs
out
to sit down with the Russell and Simba
um and other icons like J styling
um but you see people that are
transitioning you see the filthy riches
that are transitioning from an artist to
CEOs to label so he's given a lot of
these artists chances to be heard
um
then you have the underground guys that
are working still trying to figure it
out on their own you have people like
um in different areas every region has
they're different you got the All Blacks
try tall black all said Jim you know
those guys that have their fan bases
they're running
um
and and and they're working man they're
working
um and I'm just happy to see these guys
I'm happy to see these guys but one one
thing that I'm super proud of is you
know San Francisco the little beans and
the Zay bangs and the little peats like
these are guys that are doing numbers
yeah San Francisco I feel like kind of
like musically was like the least
popping City in the bay for a long time
was we think of the guys who came from
Vallejo and Oakland but now like you
said San Francisco's kind of on fire
by the way Larry June is also the
hottest the hottest I mean there's no
one hotter than Larry Jones I just gave
Larry June a serious bag to do my
nightclub last week and it was it was a
good turnout like there's there's no one
nobody in California I'm gonna say that
that if you put
if we talk about independent structure
we talk about you put you say that Mary
June's coming and then somebody else
they're going to go to the Larry June
show that's fair like I've I've watched
Larry June's sellout shows not only in
the states everywhere but we were we
were in Amsterdam and he had a show and
everything is sold out like like Larry
Jones selling out shows all around the
world
independent independent and I want to
say this doing festivals I want to say
this
um
to the to the disturbances is what I
like to call people
as of late in the past couple weeks or
so there's been
internet turmoil where people are trying
to say that Larry June
has taken Dom's Style
Dom Kennedy and I want to say this
this is where hip-hop becomes our own
worst enemies where fans begin to try to
turn on people or they begin to try to
turn artists against each other and they
begin to create narratives these
narratives that are false right both of
those guys are extremely talented
artists both of those guys have uh
rolled in the same Lane of life we are
in California so we've been exposed to
the same level of culture just different
perspectives one from Northern
California one from Southern California
so before you guys began to turn them
brothers against each other let's be
able to say let's push The Narrative of
them doing a tour together them doing
songs together them continuing to create
and and come together so that narrative
begins broken and now you can see more
people being able to be employed and
taking care of themselves and it's also
not like Larry June just popped up like
Larry Jones been I got when we get the
record with Larry Jonah we did years ago
this is like like he's been at least 10
years I don't know like people OG Mako
like he he was he was he was on tour
with Mako years ago like you feel me
like like June June is and June comes
from it June's like a direct descendant
of rbl like this that he's the child of
big June was in rbl so like you know
saying when you see rbl these guys are
icons that sold several records Gold
Records at a time where you know
San Francisco wasn't even getting
credited for that these dudes did that
so this dude he's not somebody that he
really from it right right like June is
really that dude like he really from it
so don't don't create those narratives
man but Larry Jones Larry Jones on fire
kamiya is doing her job I love Kamaya
she's a she's such a sweetheart
um
and like I say it's so many other
artists man that are that are working
that are thriving that are doing a damn
thing man and I'm I'm happy man I'm
happy to see these young guys
get a chance to
make something of themselves with their
talent right that's a blessing
that's a blessed man to be able to say
you got these guys like cash click bug
he's from Richmond and
man they on fire man they like they they
working and they grinding they they
doing their thing man and I'm just I'm
just so proud of them
um you got bread bro who just signed
with Lil Durk he's a dude from West
Oakland you got the years the Catos the
lingos and
please blame the head and not the heart
but to all of the dudes that's working
out there in the Bay Area man keep going
keep pushing because y'all doing a hell
of a job man right for sure no thanks
it's also dope to kind of see like a
it's wild because I feel like
you can speak to why you think Detroit
and Oakland because I've talked to
Detroit guys about this it feels like
the Troy Oakland and San Francisco
there's like a cousins yeah yeah it's
you know there's a lot of cousins
similarities in the music and the hustle
and the game and you know when you you a
lot of Detroit guys very very big in in
the best man cousins man they're
definitely because people forget
two short-discovered Kid Rock
facts back in the day because Kid Rock
was on drive for like you know I'm
saying people people forget that and
when Kid Rock had the [__] dude yeah
the high top high top yep so like people
forget that right so
the Bay Area and Michigan have always
been
one of the same like you know I'm saying
like they're cousins right
E40 be legit are like icons there that's
why Big Sean wanted to do the record
with 40. yep you know I'm saying like
that that connection is it's been there
right you know so it's so identical same
culture same Lifestyle the player won't
you know popping it the hustling you
know so a lot of that the market is the
same so Dej Loaf her first big Market
that she blew up in was the Bay before
the rest of the country even heard of
her try me was a number one record in
Oakland in the bay
um all of the Detroit guys man they're
they're they get they get love filthy is
huge in Detroit huge he's out there a
lot like filthy goes to Detroit and you
would think that he's from there right
like you know what I mean he's taking
his whole crew mazi's huge out there
mozzie is huge out there like you know
what I mean these guys
um have crazy famous I remember I went
out there to Detroit and I was shocked
that people knew who I was I was like
right they like fat oh my God like bro
that's crazy like cause during our
Movement we never went out there right
so it's like damn we could we could have
been getting lit over here yeah yeah
like yeah
seeing me and Uncle was like bro I love
y'all like like I'm saying like I was
like yo that's crazy right so it's
definitely the similarities are you know
it's it's the same in culture so Oakland
and Detroit the whole Bay Area in
Detroit man is definitely uh you know
they they they they they side by side in
culture and fans and so it's dope well
once upon a time you know the bay did
have a bit of like a you know Drive
records had an office there
um a lot of the music industry was based
in San Francisco and I talked to Ghazi
about this a lot like his mission is
kind of to
do his part to try to
bring that energy back I need to try to
bring people to to the Bay like
do you feel like you kind of have that
burden on your shoulders too to kind of
make sure like hey you know you don't
have to leave because I do feel like
there is an air and like to be fair a
lot of the bigger artists who come out
of the bay end up move into LA or they
kind of do the back and forth thing do
you feel like you still kind of can make
it nationally if you stay in the bay or
do you feel like it would be more
productive to maybe go to La for a
little bit go to Atlanta for a little
bit like it's all about what you want to
do right what do you feel is fitting for
you some people want to be famous some
people want to get paid
some people want both some people want
to be both you know
um are you willing to deal with the
restraints and the constraints that come
with that right are you ready to deal
with
um you know the the the liability that
you become that you put on yourself by
being able to have to move around and
can you afford that lifestyle right
right right you know and and these are
the things that you have to just ask
yourself
what are you willing to do I feel like
if anyone wants to continue to uh
further the trajectory of their career
they must always move around yeah you
must always be able to go connect the
dots and other areas demographics and
build and network and learn to be a
businessman in that regard and if you go
to Atlanta save some rent money right
you know you get a chance to save some
money and things of that nature and and
so it's all based off what do you want
to do what do you see fitting for
yourself um you see the guys like
coppolo 304 who's who's your star he's a
star to me for sure you know what I'm
saying and to be able to see him these
are the guys that I tell like leave I've
been told filthy right bro gold
filthy had an opportunity to be on Roc
Nation like go yeah go bro
go leave go let me feel me like you
become
a shark in a fishbowl like leave go it's
it's nothing wrong with like my
aspirations for wanting to be a
superstar Mega star died years ago right
and it wasn't like
I've settled or I've become complacent
it was just like
I'm cool I'm I'm I'm friends with the
superstars you know and I'm okay with
that I can call them those are you know
those are my should call Klay Thompson
like a car you know I could call these
people like you know I can I can pop up
you know I can have Steph come to the
neighborhood and you know come chill I
could I could do all of these things
with all the superstars I get the
features and you know I've never paid
for a feature in my life I got records
with Kendrick Lamar and all of these
guys like you know what I'm saying so
I'm okay with that right you know what I
mean but to the Next Generation if you
do want to go take that man go go move
around and that's to any artist that's
the artist from La that's the that's to
our artists from consequence New Mexico
go yeah you should definitely go like
you know I'm saying just just go go see
the world go venture out and go and go
Network like right now I live I live my
dreams vicariously through my uncle like
you know what I mean my uncle is doing
he's he's a star my uncle's bigger than
a lot of rappers where we from right now
like you know I'm saying like and so the
whole Uncle show is just like I I want
to see I love the excitement
seeing him with these major artists and
then these artists that come like that
watch our page or that see us and just
be like bro I was cracking up watching
y'all like do what you do and to me I
live it through him I get Juiced off
that man you know that's super dope
for you
do you ever see yourself retiring from
rapping I mean as long as the passion
and the loves there like we're talking
earlier I'm sure you're just gonna you
know just keep keep it going because why
not I'm a writer so I don't I don't just
rap like you know like I've wrote
platinum and gold records for several
artists right like I'm saying I think
that's one thing that has always you
know kept me around the basket
yeah I can you know I write for several
artists you know knowingly and those
that you're like oh I didn't know you
were okay I didn't know you wrote that
so um so I love this music and like I
say my Idols aren't just rappers like my
Idols are the Quincy Jones isn't right
you know the Miles Davis and people that
uh have contributed to music in ways
that
um have surpassed just
the rapper mentality like you know what
I mean and so I'll always stay around it
I love it yeah I love it and then you
know
my hip-hop Dad too short it's like 58
years old
still on tour Mount Westmore
still like grossing 15 20 million a year
from rat at 57 58 years old still coming
with records still being sought after
what's your favorite too short album
what's up guys hey shout out to our
family at uh Bluetooth man listen I know
we always are getting feedback about our
Bluetooth interviews
they're not interviews yeah they're
commercials and we're always getting
feedback about them usually it's they're
[__] hilarious man
you know people love it when we talk
about Bluetooth but let me say this [__]
works a lot of people are like look man
I see you talking about Bluetooth but
does it work yes it works if y'all don't
know Bluetooth it's got the same active
ingredient as Viagra and Cialis but in a
chewable form it's delivered to your
door
in a discreet package and you don't have
to go inside of a doctor's office to get
it no awkward doctor visits involved
everything is online that's right you go
to bluetooth.com use the promo code
bootleg they will send you a month for
free a month supply of Bluetooth for
free five dollar shipping that's it and
they'll be like damn Kev
you were right bro my erections are lit
as they should be every
erection should be
as erect as possible you know you don't
want to be flaccid you don't want to be
one of those 70 30 guys you know that
means that 30 of your dicks potentially
hardness is being uh
underutilized
could you use an extra 30 hard maybe 50
hard I don't know it depends on what
you're dealing with they're dealing with
stress in your life
are you tired of having sex with your
girlfriend
hard to get it up well go to
bluetooth.com right now use the promo
code bootleg they're going to send you a
month for free they also just drop the
mint chewable same active ingredient as
Levitra that's right so what you need to
do
I mean you don't need to do anything if
you want to you know not be as hard as
you can be that's on you but
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
and try it for free a month supply free
delivered to your door no awkward doctor
appointment needed it's all online all
right bluetooth.com
also want to shout out to our family
over at Odd Socks that's right as
someone who wears Odd Socks every day
I'll prove it to you
I'm in Arizona right now this is just
random
we got The Odd Socks underwear right
there I mean that's Odd Socks and we got
the odd Sox Basics baby yeah so look so
this was stuff about odd stocks man
um not only do they got the most
comfortable socks in the world because
they do I'm not just saying that because
they sponsor our show it's true uh they
also got some of the crazy licenses they
just got Coca-Cola uh they got Doritos
they got [__] everything they got
Scarface Godfather
uh Breaking Bad WWE we can go on and on
and on underwear socks slippers hats all
kinds of cool stuff oddsoxofficial.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you will save 20 off at checkout try the
odd Sox Basics if you're one of those
guys who wears other plain white branded
socks plain black socks I promise you go
with the odd Sox basics
and you will believe me but just you
will convert over they're way more
comfortable
they're way more durable
and they just they're Odd Socks why
would you wear those other socks we
could wear on socks bro Stand Down be
odd go to oddsocksofficial.com use the
promo code bootleg
let's get back to the interview
getting it getting it's the one but you
know what's crazy I feel like life is
too short was like I think that was like
way yeah well that was like but like
cuss words I just remember learning cuss
words by heart as a kid because it was
like one of the few rap albums my dad
had short dog like I mean like I said
that's my hip-hop dad that's the dude
who you know I call Pops who has taken
me all around the world with him who has
shown me in his most horrific
way of teaching
you just like someone just told me uh
well never mind I don't know I'm
probably not someone's gonna be playing
too short in a movie or a show yeah
Simba oh I didn't know no it's public
it's public okay I didn't know that it's
public he looks just like him dead on
him it's [__] crazy dead on him he
got the tooth and everything the coat
the hat to the back it was like he so he
called me
he called me was like
big bro can you put me on the phone with
short man I just want to show him this
little thing so I FaceTiming we all he
was like sure was like oh that's crazy
crazy so
and then that right there like that
alone man is just crazy I mean like you
know short is um
short of somebody who
they'll never give them his credit right
like unfortunately it's going to take
for him to ascend after this long and
for people to really be like damn he was
on life after death he was on volume two
any major album I mean Too Short like
when I was a kid I thought too short was
the biggest rapper in the world to me
like as a little kid I was like
short is the only artist and not to cut
you off I apologize nah short is the
only artist that has a song with biggie
pot Jay-Z Pimp C
yeah yeah it's like a hit anybody you
name he had his Atlanta run like anybody
you name short has records with the
first time on their album the first time
I ever heard uh Little John was that let
my nuts go right he shine Little John he
signed Little John at 17 and then was so
player he let him go for nothing
like when the major labels wanted to get
little John he John was like man can I
get out this contract and he let him go
he was like go ahead like I'm not do
your thing do your thing and that's why
to this day they have the greatest
relationship and friendship like John
demner just got him The Residency short
big shout outs to short just got a
residency in Vegas
one of them clubs like this is short man
like shortest like I brag and I talk
about him more than he does for himself
like I'm his voice I'm his I'm his come
on like I'm saying and it's just because
I I don't like the way that the industry
tries to normal normalize what he has
done for hip-hop right like how many
people that you know that you can say
was famous
as a rapper in 1982.
it's crazy
like bro that's 40 Years bro 41 years
where he was a known rapper famous
really like him and iced tea in terms of
this side yeah actually just them too
come on bro like yeah like you see ice
get his star love Uncle ice that's huge
you sure needs one why not yeah like one
has who has just tell me who has done
more than Too Short in Hip Hop for the
past 40 years right yeah it's crazy 40
like four and we're not just talking
about like four 40 years I'm talking
about this dude got songs with Lady Gaga
like he's like this is short yeah like
this is short walking up into the
Playboy Mansion I was a kid he walks up
Hugh Hefner walks up to him and was like
what's up Todd I'm like bro UF knows you
by your name this is crazy like yourself
this is crazy to me bro like nobody's
bigger than too short in my eyes man and
like I say man like even right now and I
just text him and he's like
till this day
pops what you doing man I'm in the
studio man I'm in the lab man
like he's like I'm stealing it like
every he's still there like this is
crazy bro so
I mean if it's all right can I bring my
uncle up yes do it yeah what's up man
come here man we're gonna
you said what
are you on you want your own we gotta do
his own we gotta do his own oh you want
your own interview
so you're not gonna come up
what's he saying what are you saying
oh yo you want to come over here come on
man come on get go ahead
first time ever take over
yeah
so you took over the show yes it's no
longer bootleg catch up it's bootleg up
boo like ain't nothing like about me
don't get it messed up either so what
are you doing man I'm doing the bootleg
Kev takeover about him so what's up man
first to be done I have three questions
for you what so they're serious
questions don't be this could be funny
don't mean everything is funny
are you ready maybe I take my interview
seriously I'm ready man I'm ready let me
get serious let me get back to interview
mode all right you ready all right what
so you know um growing up in the um in
the hood or the urban communities
however you want to address it a lot of
our kids come up
without being properly trained how to
have dreams goals and how to accomplish
them a lot of us we just go through life
trying to survive and trying to figure
it out because no one invested in US
that we can be anything we want to be
you know some people you know certain
households
their their parents really invest in
them they you know they push them to be
great they um
they enroll him and uh all these
activities as kids so they don't really
have free time to be able to run around
and do other stuff so what is something
that you would some advice that you
would give a kid about chasing dreams
um
great question I feel like the the
greatest advice is never be afraid to
dream never be afraid to be more than
what you are
never be afraid to uh venture out
outside of the walls that have us
confined to our neighborhoods when we
had our project buildings we had that
gate and in that gate we never thought
that there could be life outside of that
gate we didn't see a possibility outside
of those four corners that we called our
Hood our block it was the story it was
the school it was the turf it was the
steps and outside of that we felt like
there was nowhere place no place for us
and the greatest thing that my mother
did for me was she cultivated my
imagination all right she allowed me to
have an imagination because in order to
surpass those walls and those blocks and
those Corners that we come from the only
way they were able to fly over them is
through our imagination
and my greatest advice to these children
to these kids to parents to big homies
to anybody that comes from our areas
never corrupt a child's imagination
allow them to do that like I told a
person on Christmas you believe that you
know whatever you believe in allow that
child to believe in saying allow that
girl to have her imaginary friend that
she talks to that doll that she talks to
allow that kid to you know imagine right
imagine because sometimes your
imagination is the only thing that can
get you out of those situations yeah
because you can become so consumed by
what your day the reality is
unfortunately reality around you that
you that a drink like something that you
would think is possible for you you
would think that your situation in life
what won't make it takes you out of the
uh equation you know to reach those
things for sure why so serious today
though I thought you was gonna get on
here no I got another question nephew up
you taking over his own interview what
do you mean why are you he ain't
sweating me why are you sweating me
what's the next question so the next
question is right nephew along our
journey in life a lot of things happen
that we may not be ready for we not we
may not be um willing or ready to take
on but we have no choice because
um it's just what comes with their our
journey in life like we don't be able to
pick what's ahead of us right we we only
can prepare ourselves to deal with it
when we get there
I don't like to use the word regret so
I'm gonna say what is one mistake you
may have made in your rap career that
you can explain that may give another
up-and-coming rapper
um some knowledge on what maybe he might
not want to do when it comes to his
career that may
um prevent him from you know maybe um
shortening his career maybe making it
take go a little slower like what is
something what is the mistake that you
may have made that somebody else may be
able to get something out of the
difference between confidence and
arrogance
coming up
I've always been confident all right
but sometimes we don't understand that
there's a difference between confidence
and arrogance arrogance is uh
it's a it's a thin line between being
humble and being hubris and that
arrogance is the thing that offends
people right and you're intentionally
sliding someone
just because you may want them to look
at you a certain way or you want them to
put some certain respect on it and
there's no need to do that like if
you're a good person there's no need to
treat anyone bad right just because you
got money don't mean that you need to
look down on people and I think in the
early stages of my career I allow my
arrogance to override my natural
confidence because you can still be
confident and still be a humble
individual yeah because I was going to
have an extra I was going to add on to
that do you think that some people be
arrogant because personally they don't
have they that they're really not as
confident as they think they lack
confidence so they really they really
try to uh be macho what they are they
they're confident they try to be macho
because they because confidence come
with like a control Factor right you
understand me and it teaches you I'm
confident enough to know that when I
come in here I don't have to be arrogant
right I never thought that I was better
than anyone but I knew that I worked
harder
and sometimes
that can
activate some people's insecurities
right and then your arrogance
overrides it so now they look at
confidence is Steph Curry pulling up
from half court feeling like I can make
the shot right
some people would be like oh he arrogant
he shot it from one nah that's just
confidence yeah because when they ask
him man why did you shoot that shot him
I felt like I could make it right right
it wasn't oh I knew I could make it I
won't nah that arrogance sometimes is a
sucker complex yeah that's right I mean
I'm saying yeah you you a suck a complex
word the guys that act hell are tough or
the females that act most of the girls
that be mean as hell be real sweethearts
right that's their defense mechanism so
I allow my arrogance to become a defense
mechanism and um I offended certain
individuals and I'm thankful that I did
it because it taught me the lesson
because I wouldn't be able to know right
so uh there's no regret to it um but it
was just a mistake it wasn't one of
usually yeah it was a mistake a mistake
you know and you learn from it right and
and you build on
okay my last question is this if you had
the opportunity to um
to really be able to uh do an album or
or participate or write or do anything
musically with one artist who would that
artist be and why Sam Cook to me Sam
Cook was the greatest uh artist of our
time uh it wasn't my time but just of
that genre of music Soul music
um Not only was Sam Cooke uh
a great artist he was a brilliant
songwriter but something that trumps all
of that is at a time where black men
didn't own their music or black men
didn't have anything the black artists
at that time would receive pennies this
man owned his own label right he owned
his own label he signed his own artists
he did a lot of things that was uh he
trumped everyone that was around at that
time
Soulful he was a superstar he was a
super duper Star
um and
I would love to do something with Sam
Cook man like Sam Cooke to me
um he was the greatest man but uh I love
your questions I love your seriousness
good job and I appreciate care for
letting us rock man the air away
let's wrap it up let's wrap it up man
let's man listen the next time I see you
I need some of these things Hey Hey
listen we got we got you on the dope
area everything and we would love for
you to come up man so next time I'm in
the bay I I'll be out there soon we're
gonna do so what what I've been doing
um
we've been doing these things to just
help the artists I'll be out there to
watch the Suns eliminate you guys in the
playoffs so yeah
wow I'm gonna catch a game go watch you
know go watch Katie come back well if
that's the case we need to take
advantage of him coming to see famous
lose and why there do something amazing
we're gonna throw something stupid let's
do it we're gonna do the watch party at
the club right whatever we got to do go
to the game I'll be super excited to
watch you guys lose to the suns in the
playoffs this year yeah can I ask you a
question huh
do you honestly think that Phoenix is
going to win like let's talk sports okay
okay okay if Katie is if everyone's
Health wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait you're talking about a Phoenix
Suns team that were able to reach the
semi-conference finals without a KD so
now it's a if KD
well first of all we just got rid of Cam
Johnson and Mikhail Bridges who were
very important parts of that team okay
two
Kevin Durant is healthy I don't think
anyone's gonna beat us
you know a little something about
putting a little extra on top of a team
that was already on fire 73-9 and nine
team adding Kevin Durant so you know you
and I were both the same now yeah but
the only thing is we have I had a ring
before him I yeah but that was because
Kyrie Irving Kevin Love were [__] up
are we gonna use because
shout out to dellavedova still gave
Steph some help let's just be listen wow
this is just crazy we find any way to
say to take away we had a ring before
Katie and we have a ring after Katie so
now
is the pressure on female can I be
honest with you or the one the most
important and best ring you guys won was
last year's ring yeah it was a great
Ring no that's the best ring you guys
ever won because there's no there's no
caveat or asterisk to that ring
so there's an aspect to our other Rings
because of injuries because people
weren't able to endure a full season and
stay healthy that's our fault
like I said
and we went on the court last year is
your most respected ring you've got can
you at least agree on that I love that
ring last year but do you think it's the
most
and when it comes to Integrity nobody
could say [__] about last year
you guys were you guys nobody gave you
guys a chance you guys won the [__]
Championship you played a great Celtics
team who are the favorites this year
and there was no there was no
Shenanigans I love that ring I love last
year's ring I love the effort
collectively that the fellas did um
um we were able to you know I don't know
what it's like to have a championship I
know and that's that sucks I don't even
know what that is like never understand
this conversation
um but the beauty of it is I think the
ring that we missed out on was the most
important to me which is crazy like the
73-9 yeah that was that was
heartbreaking um it's okay because you
guys added KD to that team and then yeah
it was and then you ruined the league
for a couple weeks sometimes a loss that
humbles you is far greater than a win
that adds to your arrogance well I sure
hope that we ruin the league for the
next few years too with it it's not
gonna happen like Chris Chris Paul's not
a winner
here we go he's never won anything he
didn't win at Georgia Tech he did he's
never won he never won in New Orleans
he's never won in La when he had the
greatest
one what Blake Griffin and DeAndre
Jordan it was alley-oop Central Lob City
the greatest though I mean for that time
an athletic in his prime Blake Griffin
dunking over anyone all you got to do is
throw the ball up and you couldn't win
you lose you come down 3-1 you lose that
they had bad injury luck man Chris Paul
will forever had bad luck somewhere
except this year somewhere along life
you know I'm saying the only thing that
he did was what he did and hmm
what he did to that woman and how do you
feel about uh how do you feel about uh
this is are we can we make a prediction
that this is draymond's final year with
the Warriors no you think he's Stan
um I think the Warriors organization
know how important they know how
important Draymond is um I think he
wants to go to the Lakers and play with
his best bud man I think he definitely
wants to go to the Lakers just based off
the fact Rich Paul and his whole
management agency his bestie and you
know and LeBron him and LeBron are
definitely friends but I would have
thought that they'd be ended up being
best friends after he nailed him in the
nuts and cost him the ring
here we go yeah
um who would have thought and then
they're gonna end up playing together
next year it's going to be Draymond and
Dilo and hey D you know what's weird Ron
if the Warriors don't pay Bob Myers then
Draymond leaves true if I heard that he
might leave he he might go to the Lakers
you know he might go to the Lakers so if
I just can't wait for your Dynasty to be
over because I I have no nothing against
fans from the Bay who are Warrior
supporters but it's these [__] you
guys are like the new Cowboys fans it's
crazy
dealing with Warriors fans who aren't
from the [__] Bay is ridiculous oh
like I mean it's it's like it's like
it's like John Cena fans are you being
watching more Warriors fans of course
you're a [__] John Cena fan that's
real [__] convenient are you more are
you mad because there's more Warrior
fans at the Suns game do you see that
that's 10 years old but all right listen
is that a Joe Smith Jersey buddy that's
Tyrone Hill buddy Tyrone Hill okay first
of all Joe Smith were the same number
right most definitely would that be that
just lets you know how long ago that was
brother I didn't say you were in a real
no I'm just saying because I I just feel
like I have right to talk about this
conversation regardless if our dynasty
was supposed to be over when we when
Steph Was Heard and we only won I was
excited I was excited so you want to see
us lose for sure why I [__] hate the
Warriors man that's crazy how did the
Phoenix Suns Phoenix Suns fan establish
this much hatred for the Warriors you
know why because my favorite player is
that guy right there the statue LeBron
James I love LeBron yeah
listen the suns were like the [__]
Dan Marley I love Kevin Johnson I like
Charles Barkley I love Cedric sabales I
love Wayman Tisdale
wow
I'm real basketball Tisdale on the
Warriors no he didn't play for us he'd
play for the Suns no but he wasn't on
the Warriors for a little bit um
all right no so like when he was when he
was on the Suns he put out a jazz album
yeah he did he played the bass yeah uh I
I I love the Phoenix Suns I love you
know I love what you do I love Tom
Chambers everything that you got I could
never see myself wanting to see a team
just deliberately lose I don't know
that's where you and I yeah are
different I do I want to see the
Warriors January 27th and you're an
aquarius how can this be I'm an aquarius
why are you act like this I [__] hate
the Warriors that's crazy yeah I'm over
it we're going to continue this Sports
show I'm over this [__] man
hey man thank you though brother of
course bro I appreciate you yes sir for
real man um as always nothing but love
Northern California Southern California
let's continue to keep be able to create
and show the world man that California
is amen we're one of the most creative
places in the world let's continue to
keep working together artists and keep
building uh and Central Cali these high
taxes and yes definitely expensive to
live here man Uncle Fab show going
worldwide man and uh I thank you man
thank you appreciate it there it is